organelles are the specialized parts of  a cell that have unique jobs to perform  let's start with the nucleus the control  center of the cell the nucleus contains  DNA or genetic material the nucleus also  contains a nucleolus which is a  structure where ribosomes are made  ribosomes may wander freely within the  cytoplasm or attached to the endoplasmic  reticulum sometimes abbreviated as ER  proteins and other materials emerge from  the endoplasmic reticulum in small  vesicles where the Golgi apparatus  sometimes called the Golgi body receives  them the mitochondrion is an organelle  that is the powerhouse for both animal  and plant cells during a process called  cellular respiration the mitochondria  make ATP molecules that provide the  energy for all of the cell's activities